today on our show we are going deep into
the Golden Circle that's [ __ ] dirty
tell me more about it
oh oh it's a movie review yes Ari did
not [ __ ] today on fat men are bad we're
not talking about the Golden Circle
they're logging about Kingsman the
Golden Circle
- that men on Batman welcome the fat man
Batman I'm Kevin stone mark barnard hey
don't think that my initial
unenthusiastic response is a review of
the movie because I didn't see it
mmm and if you're like well then how are
you gonna review it well I'm not I'm
gonna sit here and watch a guy who
[ __ ] saw it talk about it so just
like you you a mirror in the same boat
this week it's a theater in the round
yeah normally like you watch people
[ __ ] talk down just like you the
whole time I'm I'm put myself in the
viewers position this week well done
yeah where do you come down on the first
Kingsman picture this Kingsman picture
by Matthew Vaughn I thought it was a lot
of fun I didn't expect you know much of
it not that I was like the only dumb cuz
I think Matthew Vaughn clearly knows
that a [ __ ] direct and move a camera
or make an effect out of the moving of a
camera and stuff like that but you know
I was it was like well this seems I like
Britain the Brits and Irish movies but
this seemed a little too archly Brit or
whatever from the first trailer I saw
but I liked Colin Firth so I was like I
might be way into this then I saw the
movie and so I guess I'm saying all that
because my expectations weren't way high
they were like yeah sure this will be
way to pass the time I [ __ ] loved it
like I thought was genius that [ __ ]
church shootout it's amazing it's
fantastic spellbinding that lady running
on for The Mummy when she's running on
the knives and stuff I thought that was
real I thought she had those legs they
found an actress like they're casting a
disabled person as a kung-fu killer I
thought that's what it was it wasn't but
whatever but that movie was really
[ __ ] tight wonderful and then kind of
[ __ ] a you know joke in it at the end
it didn't have an anal joke which is a
divisive little bit of an end of a movie
yeah it was you know I could see that
I'm not I'll be honest with you I
thought it was [ __ ] funny because I
was like holy [ __ ] that where we are you
know you gotta remember I'm the guy who
used to make movies that push the edge
of the envelope so when I see the
envelope get pushed like there are two
moments I saw something in the movie
over the last few years where I was like
holy [ __ ] you could do that now what's
his name picking up his dick with his
mouth at the end of of 21 Jump Street
uh-huh Rob Riggle that was it I was like
you could do that in a movie now and get
an R and
and then what was the other thing this
anal sex anal anal sex as lure to get
you here to save the world as that joke
like I was like holy [ __ ] man afterwards
you couldn't do it in the bum yes it was
crazy I was like you could say that I
mean I know you could always make a
rectal joke but like it was just at that
moment in an action movie like I don't
know I enjoyed that movie yeah they
didn't lose me with that I'll tell you
that much
I think they lost my wife at that joke
yeah I feel like you know for many
people and kind of myself included it it
was an unnecessary swerve in dude in
like the butthole joke
like I I about old associated it fully
like we're going for it
but also thought it was like wholly
unnecessary and you could have got away
with not doing it absolutely feel like
you know look this is what I'll say that
definitely felt like the work of
distinctive voice of a filmmaker he
knows like that seems like a Matthew
bond so the picture took a moment to
have and stuff while still being within
the realm you know I'm not Ram to me but
at the same time I was like cool [ __ ]
for this yeah I felt like it was a
pretty smart updating over the James
Bond sort of mythos yes because
ultimately that's what it is and the guy
who deserves the credit for that is Mark
Moore right Lepidus right yeah but and
and Dave Gibbons is a genius of course
who's co-creator of the Watchmen but
mark as we all know is a [ __ ] insane
creative force he got a big old fat deal
at Netflix they bought Millar world and
stuff but like kick-ass was his and then
Kingsman was his as well and you know it
he he came up with some cool [ __ ] yeah
really and it was he created a whole
cloth like granted there's a lot of
tropes from comic books and [ __ ] but
like you know weird it is that somebody
creates a new comic book franchise one
Marvel or DC so like you know your hats
off to the fact that they made it work
once and it worked I mean yes so much so
that Matthew Baum went and did another
one they did really well I think did you
saw I did see the first one came out and
I want to say March of
three years ago yeah felt undersold to
like I didn't feel like I'm feeling this
one up my ass it was Valentine's Day
this was a Valentine's Day movie the
Kingsmen yeah and it made it did like
200 million domestic it made another 250
million 300 overseas like it was it was
a hit that nobody saw coming yeah except
for Fox who was very very happy about it
and so they made a sequel which both
advances the story like eggsy the Taron
Egerton the first the kid kind of scav
underworld kid who gets you know the
little nod from a knight ultimately in
colin firth who says you should join the
Kingsmen a secret independent espionage
organization it saves the world on a
regular basis this movie is about
manners maketh the man yes Harry
dies at the end of the first movie not
even middle yeah yeah like middle of
that first movie they take Colin Firth
out yeah and so I saw him in a trailers
for this this this movie is very much
about eggsy learning to both deal with
the loss of a father figure and if
you've seen the trailers you also know
that they destroy the Kingsmen
headquarters and to kill most of the
agents can do that movie there no nor
should you
and so this movie opens with a opens
with this their amazing scene it's
action beat which one that we've seen in
the trailer it's this the one where he's
like riding on the top of the black cab
in London and leaps over [ __ ] and that
entire sequence is scored - lets go
crazy by prints which is the first time
since Prince has been making music that
a prince song has been in a movie that
Prince was not in he wrote the music for
Batman so it's belongs to Batman right
but and he wrote the music all the music
front of the Train nobody's used let's
go crazy since Prince used it and
Interpol right yeah because he never
allowed for the licensing of his own
song I can say that for
from from experience yes you grab down
miracle knowledge of this purple path
Jay and Silent Bob strike back there was
usage when we saw the homegirl for the
first time Shannon Elizabeth when she
came into the movies I used the most
beautiful girl in the world and he then
like while we were in post on Jay and
Silent Bob strike back what the same
time that I cut that song in mmm-hmm
prints got in touch with me about like
oh I saw Dogma and I want to do
documentary and I've told that print
story of gazillion times on evening with
Kevin Smith DVD but uh since he was
asking me to do something I was like oh
I can ask ya a little quid pro quo quid
pro quo
I really Sam Prince pro quo or quited
Prince quo
took a few draft iteration and so as I
came in I like I'm using I wanted to use
most beautiful girl in the world and Jay
and Silent Bob strike back so can like
luck we're happy to pay for it but can I
use it and he goes no nope and flat out
but we use the time song cuz he owns the
publishing on that so that was a thing
but he would not let one of his songs I
know that from experiences live
performances videos rarely could find on
YouTube true but he would shut [ __ ] down
on the regular even fan fan sites yeah
you couldn't like his his Super Bowl
performance
you couldn't find legally on the
internet anywhere because it's like
listen my music I performed it it
belongs to me no and like if you can
tell the NFL no that's a lot of no and
so in in his path that on a bumper
sticker it's a lot in America in his
passing the the restrictions on the use
of his music has slipped a little bit
lifted considerably considerably so a
lot of those all performances are now
back online
you're now like stars as airing drug
inside of the times like there's no
tomorrow and so when when Matthew Vaughn
at Fox went and said hey do you think we
could use a print song there like you'd
be the first it'll cost you
but yeah you can have like let's go
crazy how much do you think that song
I don't I don't know the range honestly
of song clearances - we paid a quarter
of a million dollars for tusks on tusks
by Fleetwood Mac so that's that movie
that's that movie this thing in that
song so what the first time anyone's
used a prince song other than Prince in
a movie Fox plays already spent 100 200
million whatever [ __ ] on it
they're not gonna stop now with all the
marketing this is a seven-figure
clearance easy I get you I guarantee get
like 2 to 5 million yeah for the use of
that yeah
and it's a great scene and it really
works because it's it's a ton of fun but
so yeah the movie is about eggsy sort of
in the next phase of his career that
Swedish princess who he had a little
backdoor affair with at the end of the
first movie is now his girlfriend and so
he's like wanting to meet her family who
wore it's [ __ ] the king of Sweden so
he bought back the joke he brought back
the gym no bought back the G did like
you know at the if you're mad that like
oh come on giving up never but sex be
like they became a couple yeah that was
that was the entree to a real
relationship yeah and it's a sweet
relationship it's actually gonna live
like the whole movie it plays the whole
movie there's even a bit in a sort of
nice and this is a slight spoiler so
there's going to be spoilers so fYI
spoilers are coming you can count it
down five four three two one spoilers
this is a bit where eggsy has to go to
the Glastonbury music festival to find a
source that he's got a track to the big
bad guys lair okay so it's a it's a girl
it's the girlfriend of the bad guy
henchmen and she's partying at glass toe
blaster what happened to galactose is a
glass toe so eggsy has to plant a
tracker on her and the the gig is well
according to Merlin played by Mark
Strong who's awesome he says well it
needs it needs to be planted in a in a
soft fleshy place it's got to be the
conditions have to be just right in
order for us to track this wherever it
goes yes eyeko so like get a behind the
ear no no well I get in the mouth no no
and he opens up this case and there's
this little tiny condom
like this big syke Nelly put it on your
finger and you just have to insert it
somewhere on her body so he then like
goes into this tent and they're about to
all get into it
said listen I gotta go the bathroom I'll
be right back and he calls his
girlfriend and says listen I have to
[ __ ] this girl to save the world but I'm
not gonna do it unless you tell me it's
okay which is this kind of lovely
subverting of the James Bond thing which
is all he does his runs are [ __ ]
everybody around the world for kind of
no reason at all and and there's no
repercussions for any of it I mean J
response would be riddled with STDs but
that goes beyond the point and so for
him to be like hey so is it cool if I
[ __ ] this girl to do this thing and
should you spoil it spoilers spoilers
five he's gonna tell you whatever they
do it or not for cuz I have no
imagination three and I'll still go see
it I don't mind spoilers
- here comes [ __ ] one he does
not [ __ ] her but he does go - I suppose
this qualifies as third base in which he
puts the thing on his finger and inserts
it into her vagine and the camera does
that thing where he like pushes in
between this girl's legs she's still got
her panties on you see his finger going
underneath and inside and then it pushes
inside like past the panties real fast
and so you're not inside the sugar walls
Prince never being very presumptuous
that's it I bet we all came from there I
know this is the only way through I can
show you things in sections avoid that
sugar walls good point so that song
works mm-hmm only if you're a c-section
baby because otherwise you can beat the
singer at her own game even though it
was written by Prince right be like look
I've seen sugar walls firsthand but so
that's how you win an argument machine
Easton case anyone out there is my baby
drives to work doesn't take the morning
train that's the other way to beat her
now if you get the abuse to say his name
three
times or whatever how do you make him go
away I don't remember I think Harry
Belafonte is involved you get him there
by saying his name three times and then
do you just say his name three more time
yeah you just say three more times since
that's it that seems kind of arbitrary
yeah guys remember he kept like [ __ ]
table yeah no Beatle right all right
anyway so yes he fingers his girl plants
his tracker and moves on um God Mark
sounded like a teenager in the 80s
fingers this girl fingers is girl and
it's it's the scene that both shows a
sort of maturity on your characters part
and also the propensity for this film to
push in ways literally that it probably
doesn't need to go and if you're gonna
push in that way why isn't it just a
condom anywheres on his [ __ ] dick why
doesn't he actually have to [ __ ] this
girl in order for him to plant this
tracker why is it a tiny kind of not a
big condom and if they really wanted to
[ __ ] push it if you really want it to
be transgressive about it the source
should have been a guy like that's good
thinking right you know like where he's
got a call the girlfriend to be like
they want me to [ __ ] this I got a [ __ ]
this dude in order to save the world
like I want you to know about it
it's also so hot he's also really
handsome so so it's gonna be easy yeah
I'm not gonna be the hardest thing I've
ever had to do so yeah that's there you
go why don't they get another draft
going from old mark barnard I was just
idea those high oak sound like the kind
of jokes Kevin Smith would do if he had
a big budget that's clever I'm talking
about just feel like you know this
rubbers got a con this sounds like
something out of Jay and Silent Bob I'm
kind of proud I didn't do it yeah I mean
it it's juvenile to say the least but it
does show some growth on the characters
part and the other big invention in this
movie is the idea that with the Kingsmen
gone and eggsy by himself trying to
figure out who's who's behind the murder
of the king's men yes spoiler alert it's
Julianne Moore playing a woman named
poppy who is a drug dealer par
excellence
yeah her whole shtick is she wants to
she's laced all of the drugs she sells
which are like heroin and marijuana and
crack
can everything knotweed know the weed
she sells the weed she she laces it with
his disease that begins it manifests
first is like a blue sort of veiny thing
over your face then it moves into like
mania where you dance a lot and then it
moves into paralysis and then it moves
into death why because she's using the
she wants to force the American
president here played by Bruce Greenwood
basically playing Donald Trump to
legalize the sale of drugs that you can
then tax and control and legitimize and
and do all the things that the country
does with alcohol and tobacco she wants
drugs to get the same protections and
opened the markets in the same way and
she's going to instead use millions of
hostages to force the American president
do so clever not just like I've got to
kill right like I want to make money and
I make money selling drugs and I'm tired
of living as she does and like Cambodia
in some hollowed-out volcano / old
religious temple that she's transformed
into like this fifties recreation of
like diners and bowling alleys and she
keeps Elton John his hostage to make him
sing for her
well John gets to be people's asses of
his movie it's to what beat people's
asses he fights there was an Elton John
fight scene don't let the Sun go down on
me no
so like ultimately here's here's here's
the take oh I forgot to talk about the
Statesman which is the other big things
the Kingsmen gone they have to turn to
their American brothers The Statesman
who were formed because some like Yankee
Kentucky and had a great suit made once
on Savile Row by the Kingsmen and they
felt that they had these sort of similar
interests and caring for their countries
and had this doomsday protocol that if
something ever happened to either of the
the Kingsmen or the Statesman that the
other would come to the aid okay
and so Statesman is run by Jeff Bridges
playing codename champagne who would
they just call him champ because he's
Jeff Bridges Channing Tatum who is a
tequila and and Pedro Pascal
from from all narcos and from Game of
Thrones yes who plays whiskey and why
he's not tequila I guess because you
wouldn't do that
but the best part about Petrobras cause
he's basically playing Burt Reynolds oh
really if you see it he's got the
[ __ ] Burt Reynolds mustache and he's
gonna cowboy hat he's Burt Reynolds from
like 1982 that's genius and he's kind of
great he's a lot of fun
he's had a big year he's having a really
big year the movie works I mean it's
it's fun the action scenes are amazing
like Matthew Vaughn does that like
nobody does that right um Taron Egerton
gets to actually play some real emotion
and Colin Firth is still in it he's back
he's gonna need Ecch so the the dynamic
is like here's a son dealing with his
father who's undergoing dementia who
doesn't recognize him who doesn't know
who he is or where he came from or any
of that stuff and so it's a kind of
sweet dynamic of you know a guide trying
to pull his dad back from the brink was
he Israel dad no no father no father
figure like their dads knew each other
it's like doc and Marty totally like
eggsy's father was one of the Kingsmen
and and when he died in them and Lyme
his life kind of went down the bad road
but it's it's kind of sweet and kind of
lovely and the action is great it's
plotted however mm-hmm like a Roger
Moore Bond movie and if you haven't seen
one of those in a while spend a minute
those [ __ ] take their time like
heaven above me i watch the side of me
with girlfriends permission i watch
butyric kill
recently heavy when was the last time
you saw that honestly in a theater when
I saw theatrically Grace Jones
Christopher Walken as the American one
yeah where they spend a good 50 minutes
in that movie talking about a horse
racing and you don't know why really
we're talking about horse racing who
gives a [ __ ] ultimately it's like the
poker chips they wanted to go to
Kentucky I think they did and and again
but half of his also spent in like some
British [ __ ] Manor where they're
talking about horse racing before they
get to the states to a kill
best part of it it really kind of Duran
Duran theme zone and it was one of those
James Bond movies where they were so
fascinated by what the world was
fascinating at the time so this is like
the early 80s so it's microchips you
guys Max or and souls microchips and
what does he want to do it's it's
Goldfinger but with microchips I want to
flood Silicon Valley so that I'm the
only person in the world who sells
microchips so I'm gonna set off a bunch
of bombs underneath [ __ ] San
Bernardino and destroy Silicon Valley
that's that movie that's my plan but the
movie takes forever to get anywhere
because Roger Moore movies were never
like really motivated by entertaining
this movie kind of has a little bit of
that where it's they're just scenes that
kind of wander and you're like why are
we here where are we going what does
this mean why are we taking so long to
do these things that we know and we know
we have to do we gotta go to Glastonbury
so they can finger this girl to find the
henchmen of poppy why don't we just go
to the hills you say fingered Mike
[ __ ] sphincter well you're a man of
middle age I'm sure you've had a
proctology truly I have been fingered
then breathe deep yeah use the whole
fist doc so yeah like it's this is an
entertaining movie it's not an amazing
movie well it improves on the on the
first one in kind of emotional ways but
it devolves in a like you begin to lose
the threat of why this is also important
towards the tail end of it did business
last night it did real a good business
it'll do with that I don't know there
thing's gonna be four they're projecting
40 it could be more yeah 40 50 million
they're looking at and people have seen
it all they're going to see at this
point it'll probably be number one and
it won't disappoint anybody if you like
the first movie you'll like the second
one if you didn't like the first movie
you will similarly not like this one
but I had a good time I had a good time
it's not amazing but it's thoroughly
entertaining you heard about the Kings
man King
the man the things man the things mark
barnard that was pretty good thank you
nice job thank you very much arrived hey
um thank Mark Barnard inferred in the
[ __ ] work for you I you know it is a
hard job to have to sit in a movie
theater you sold the ticket I might
actually go I was definitely gonna watch
it when it you know hit home video but
now I'm like I like Julianne Moore
Julianne Moore is really fun I like Jeff
Bridges I like that whole [ __ ] cast
I like that Pedro guy yeah the only one
I'm unfamiliar with other than him in
the Kingsmen is the guy with yeah Taron
Egerton
who uh who you've never been related to
joel edgerton I don't believe so I think
it's a different agent in line they're
still there to [ __ ] working Holly
what are you [ __ ] me
yeah and they're not related now related
that's that's [ __ ] make a movie about
that yeah how did this go on I met him
once
yeah uh me and Matthew Vaughn story size
over in England for something completely
unrelated my agent Phil he said
endeavour well now it's WME he goes hey
men can you do me a favor do you know
kick ass I said the other comic book he
goes okay Matthew Vaughn he's my client
you know Matthew bonus yeah he's a
producer on homeboys movies uh what's
his name
you didn't layer Guy Ritchie and yeah
layered layer cakes one he directed it's
his first one so he goes he did a comic
book movie and you know he wants your
opinion and I was like oh all right and
it was screening in like a hotel that I
was staying at so it was [ __ ]
convenient as [ __ ] so my agent sold it
to me is like you got to give him some
ideas of like what to cut he's looking
for your ideas of what to cut so he's
like okay and I went and saw the movie
and [ __ ] and enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
and saw definitely some easy lifts so
then afterwards you know it's the
[ __ ] British publicist or somebody
was like this is Matthew Vaughn I was
like hey man I love the movies like Ron
Ron Thanks and I was like so you know
there's some easy lifts you can make and
like I started lifting them listing the
lifts and this dude is looking at me
with the face of like [ __ ] are you mate
like really [ __ ] mad and shitty and
about like 30 40 seconds into it
starting to realize oh he didn't ask for
this
my agent Phil was like you should go
watch this and tell him some things to
cut like as if every filmmaker wants to
hear from another filmmaker oh here's
what I would [ __ ] cry
so after about like a minute and a hat
like it midway through I realized as I
go I'm floating here by myself but I
just didn't even address I just went
well and then you couldn't lose this and
this but I thought it was really great
and he was like thanks and walked away
and you know I remember when I saw the
Kingsmen I was like I can't believe I
gave that guy advice like that guy
clearly knows what he's doing
did you uh did you tell Phil it's like
Phil I did I said you [ __ ] me right
Phil why you do that to me Phyllis cop
approached Phil you changed man there it
is man you heard the [ __ ] man go see
Kingsman door don't tell us not what you
thought don't find me on the Internet
all you have to do is go see it and then
right below us in the comment section
what you thought yeah how long I was or
how right I was [ __ ] I mean hey there
it is Batman I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Spain I am mark Renard come
back next episode we'll show you some
more [ __ ] going on pop culture landscape
same fad time same fat channel SModcast
calm or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
Gold Circle Oh
Gold sir
[Music]
[Applause]
you